un grand dépistage se tient en ce moment
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines c'est jusqu'à demain lé test
sont destinés aux salariés travaillant
dans l'agglomération l'opération
organisée en partenariat avec la rs est
gratuite et anonyme
aujourd'hui en moyenne l'équipe réalise
une centaine de tests par heure 80
entreprises se sont inscrites pour une
capacité de 2000 à 3000 tests sur ces
trois jours
premier bilan au micro de justin brasier
et de marie pas neutre à c'est très
difficile de gérer une crise pareille
avec dix sept mille entreprises si vous
lancez un appel
c'est comme on a eu des demandes aussi
d'autres catégories on a aussi nos
collaborateurs dans nos mairies voyez
mission les fait tous se passer c'est
pareil on fait sauter le chiffre dont il
faut doser
c'est pas simple mais on apprend et je
pense que la prochaine opération elle
sera encore mieux
elle portera encore plus certainement
massivement sur un nombre élevé
elle sera peut être étendue au-delà des
salariés des entreprises de saint
quentin